[Musique]
le des plus grands cratères d'impact de
la planète se trouvent au québec c'est
l'astroblème de manicouagan son relief
et nord témoigne d'un cataclysme qui
aurait profondément bouleversé la vie
marine à travers le monde il y à des
millions d'années mais aujourd'hui ce
lieu mythique abritent un écosystème
remarquable
[Musique]
voici le nouveau chapitre d'une histoire
plus vieille que l'humanité une histoire
qui commence il ya 214 millions d'années
au moment où une météorite percute la
terre de plein fouet
aujourd'hui la cicatrice est encore
visible en plein coeur du québec
son nom l'astroblème de manicouagan
un véritable musée à ciel ouvert
surnommé veille du québec
[Musique]
cinq courageux se rendront au coeur de
cette région meetic avec des
technologies haut de gamme les explorant
des paysages méconnus des scientifiques
que ça soit du drone ou de les données
bathymétriques ou même du lit d'un cd
information qui n'existe pas et donc
c'est vraiment intéressant d'aller
développer de la connaissance sur cela
erwan gavelle et le coordonnateur
scientifique de l'expédition
s'est donnée la voile à mettre à
disposition de la communauté et chaque
scientifique avec sa spécialité va
pouvoir aller analysés en fonction ses
besoins sur un lieu où
les données sont inexistantes le projet
est une initiative de l'artiste paul
d'un combat avec les données recueillies
il créera des expositions art et science
à propos de l'astroblème
les scientifiques ont palais les outils
ni le temps de valoriser toutes leurs
recherches donc nous ce qu'on propose la
partir d'une seule collecte c'est de
l'exploiter à 100% depuis la recherche
fondamentale jusqu'à la diffusion au
public 16 septembre 2021
les premiers coups de rames sonne le
départ
destination le bon babel point culminant
de l'astroblème
l'oeil du québec n'est pas un simple
cratère le choc de la météorite a formé
un trou mais la zone du milieu c'est sûr
élever comme lorsqu'une goutte d'eau
arrivent dans une flaque le mans babel
correspond aussi au point central de
l'impact pour s'y rendre il faut
traverser le réservoir manicouagan
cela calcule la profondeur de l'eau une
information clé pour retracer l'histoire
de l'astroblème car jadis le réservoir
n'existait pas il n'y avait que des lacs
et des rivières dans l'astroblème durant
les années 1960 la construction du
barrage électrique daniel johnson sur la
rivière manicouagan provoque la montée
des eaux l'astroblème prend alors sa
forme actuelle au milieu lille rené
levasseur et tout autour le réservoir
manicouagan
le sonar permet de retrouver l'ancien
rivière
lot il est à son plus profond plus de
300 mètres
des informations fournies par le sonar
sont toutefois limitées
la formation du réservoir a submergé de
vastes territoires ancestraux innu que
reste-t-il de ses forêts et ses villages
c'est comme si vous voulez retourner au
chalet de votre grand père qui est
chargé d'histoire auxquels vous n'avez
plus accès parce qu'il est maintenant
140 150 mètres en dessous de la surface
nathalie lasselin est une habituée des
plongées en milieux difficiles d'accès
elle s'est jointe au projet manicouagan
pour aller là où les kayaks ne peuvent
se rendre dans les profondeurs du
réservoir le voyez ce grand réservoir
immense
1942 kilomètres carrés ces images prix
de la station spatiale et en fouillant
aucune images sous marines et je
revenais tout simplement temps
difficile de se repérer dans les eaux
sombres du réservoir à peine huit mètres
de profondeur et c'est l'obscurité
totale
[Musique]
les seuls petits choses qui vont
refléter la lumière vont qui les
particules en suspension on a vraiment
l'impression d'être dans l'espace
les premiers arbres apparaissent
douaniers et abandonné depuis 60 ans et
pourtant ils se tiennent bien droit
les arbres au fond du réservoir
l'impression que que l'on a c'est qu'on
est vraiment dans la forêt boréale telle
qu'on la connaît la surface simplement
sous l'eau
les branches gorgée d'eau se sont
courbés vers le haut mais en l'absence
d'air les arbres ne pourrissent pas
nathalie lasselin rapportent des
échantillons pour documenter ce
phénomène on avait un guide innu qui
étaient avec nous et qui est pas
plongeurs et lorsqu'il a vu les images
de la forêt submergées il n'en revenait
pas c'était un peu comme des photos de
voyage des photos de souvenirs
quelques jours plus tard et kayakistes
arrive à bon port ce qui m'a le plus
frappé en arrivant chez dumont wells et
l'immensité du territoire et un peu la
perte de européen
l'ascension est ponctué de protocole
scientifique à suivre
l'audi d'art transforme la forêt en un
nuage de points il permet de
reconstituer chaque arbre en trois
dimensions pour identifier ses
propriétés
le drôle prend des photos à différentes
altitudes
l'assemblage des images dans le résultat
spectaculaire
un modèle 3d du bon babel
l'impact de la météorite a formé à
monterey à pic c'est ce qui fait varier
la végétation de manière fulgurante
qu'on passe d'un vestiaire à épinettes
noires à une paix ciara sapin baumier
puis à une végétation complètement ton
briques en très peu de distance et donc
c'est vraiment un lieu unique
toutes les espèces végétales sont
méticuleusement documenté nous avons
turier ramène ainsi avec eux une mine
d'or de données inédites
ces données là ça permet de
d'avoir plus d'informations sur le
territoire de mieux connaître et quand
on connaît mieux on est capable aussi de
mieux le protéger mais de comprendre que
ces forêts là sont incroyables et que
c'est important de les garder dans
lequel
le projet est loin d'être terminée avec
les données recueillies l'équipe peut
maintenant reconstruire une partie de
l'astro blême en format numérique
les chercheurs partenaires des
universités de montréal et sherbrooke
découvre ainsi ce riche écosystème qui
n'ont pas fini d'étudier de son côté
paul d'un combat transforme les données
à sa façon pour le plaisir des yeux vu
puisque on a des données spatiales
c'est aussi envisageable d'extraire des
formes physiques avec des outils par
exemple de découpe numérique ou des
imprimantes 3d à travers ses expositions
ce sera bientôt à l'artiste de nous
faire voyager dans l'oeil du québec
pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est important de
ré explorer de ré enchanter les
territoires de mélanger le numérique
avec la poésie avec la science pour
redécouvrir notre monde et proposer une
nouvelle lecture de la nature